es un fantasma que se está extendiendo
por todo el mundo el de la inseguridad
alimentaria y ahora ha llegado a américa
latina y el caribe donde cerca de 7 como
8 millones de personas podrían caer en
esta situación esto solo tomando en
cuenta inflación y crecimiento esta vez
humo que golpea mucho más el tema la
mujer que golpea a los sectores
informales que no tengo recursos para
mejorar en lo social sean cuenta que
faltó esta situación puede ser lo que
significa que millones de
latinoamericanos podrían no tener acceso
a alimentos suficientes inocuos y
nutritivos para satisfacer sus
necesidades energéticas diarias y llevar
una vida sana según la definición de
naciones unidas- un riesgo que ha
aumentado debido a un problema mundial
la guerra en ucrania conflicto que ha
disparado la inflación en casi todo el
mundo aunque los expertos advierten que
la zona ya arrastraba este problema
entre otros motivos por la pandemia de
kobe 19
exclusivamente como un efecto de esta
guerra sino que también que nace como un
efecto que nace precedentemente en
américa latina y el caribe los
indicadores de pobreza y pobreza extrema
también están al alza algo reflejado por
ejemplo en el aumento del precio de los
alimentos
estrechamente relacionado con la
inseguridad alimentaria al respecto los
expertos apuntan que las medidas para
revertir esta situación son diferentes
en cada país no obstante todos coinciden
en que deben implantarse cuanto antes